businesses find all sorts of ways to
stand apart from their competition from
cutting out the middleman to bucking the
e-commerce Trend we explore the
strategies behind some of the biggest
names in business to see what makes them
profitable unique and able to survive or
even thrive in an economic downturn
first we dive into how Trader Joe's
threatened conventional supermarkets
with its limited options and cult
favorite products these are bananas
obviously they're from Trader Joe's
today they cost 19 cents each and about
25 years ago bananas at Trader Joe's
cost 19 as of 2020 Trader Joe's gross
average sales per square foot was more
than double those of other major grocery
store chains and it's been ranked the
highest rated grocery store for customer
satisfaction so how does Trader Joe's
manage to keep prices low while outc
competing traditional grocery stores by
selling fewer
products this is the economics of Trader
Joe's Trader Joe stores are smaller and
they tend to carry fewer items and the
vast majority of what they sell is
private label when the store first
opened in 1967 Trader Joe's founder Joe
colom emphasized stocking products that
were unconventional to Shoppers at the
time like Dijon mustard and granola in
1979 Trader Joe's was bought by the
German discount grocery store chain Al
Nord and today Trader Joe's has built
its image around selling trendy quirky
and seasonal items orange chicken K
pasta sauce from Trader Joe's it helps
with fueling the experience for
customers people can go and kind of feel
like they're discovering something new
and these products have created a large
and loyal customer fan base I went to
Trader Joe's and I accidentally got I
got way too much stuff of course I love
Trader Joe's it's popularity on social
media is helpful for the company because
Trader Joe's doesn't do a lot of
advertising actually the grocery store
doesn't do a lot of things that other
grocery stores do there's no loyalty
program no online shopping platform and
no Deli counter still the Trader Joe's
fan base is strong and they are
dedicated they are Mega fans people will
sell Trader Joe's products on places
like eBay for a much higher price tag
than what you would find at the stores
Trader Joe's smaller selection can make
the inore shopping experience more
efficient for customers according to
psychologist and Professor Barry Schwarz
for example instead of having to pick
between many different brands of tomato
sauce at a conventional grocery store
customers at Trader Joe's can quickly
select one from its more limited options
by selling a small selection of house
Brands Trader Joe's can control its own
supply chain which it says brings down
prices Trader Joe's items tend to be
cheaper because they buy directly from
producers and manufacturers whenever
they can so this Cuts costs that would
typically go to the middleman and the
company says they are able to pass that
along to Shoppers Trader Joe's says it
buys in bulk and often pays for items up
front whenever possible from suppliers
this all helps lower prices the grocery
store chain also says it pays for some
products like Dijon mustard in local
currency so if the currency fluctuates
Trader Joe's takes on the risk not the
supplier and by assuming the risk Trader
Joe's says it can negotiate better
prices with suppliers this control over
its products and supply chain means
Trader Joe's can easily add and remove
items from its shelves
one of the unique things about Trader
Joe's is they're constantly changing
their shelves if products aren't selling
as well as they thought they would they
remove them from their shelves to make
room for something better some grocery
stores charge Brands various marketing
fees to stock products but Trader Joe's
says it only makes money when customers
make a purchase so according to Trader
Joe's this incentivizes it to only stock
product that customers like from JoJo's
sandwich cookies to kungpow chicken
there isn't really another chain that
does what they do there are other
Discounters that sell for cheaper but
you're not going to find the Innovation
and and the fun products there the
traditional grocery stores have tried to
go that route but Trader Joe's is Traer
Joe's let's say you wanted to buy this
Primark t-shirt if you're shopping on
primark's website you'll quick discover
that you
can't over the past 10 years e-commerce
sales have more than doubled but last
year European fast fashion retailer
Primark made 9.5 billion in sales
revenue without a single penny from
online shopping we made a very clear
choice and our Clear Choice is bricks
and mortar this comes at an uncertain
time for struggling clothing retailers
retailers like Forever 21 JC Penney and
Neiman Marcus have closed stores and
filed for bankruptcy and while a UBS
report shows up to 880,000 retail stores
will close in the next 5 years Primark
plans to expand to 60 stores in the same
time frame is driving 2 hours from
Toronto to Buffalo to shop at Primark
worth it heck yes I used to fly 6 hours
to do so so how is primar expanding
without online shopping this is the
economics of Primark fashion retailer is
is incredibly competitive more so than
ever there's not many players especially
in fast fashion that are making
fat margins pretty much the thinking
everywhere is that you have to have this
online presence but online shopping is
actually incredibly expensive for
retailers you have to have a logistical
hub from which you would dispatch the
goods and then You' probably have a
local distribution center from which you
have to do last mile delivery each step
of that just is an extra layer of cost
that just eats away at the margin which
in fashion is very very slim anyway but
the real killer for e-commerce is that
somebody who buys something on the
Internet is far more likely to return
that product than somebody who goes into
a store returns are one of the biggest
profit losses for online retailers on
average processing a return for $100
worth of merchandise bought online costs
a company $ 2650 for years online
retailers just ate these expenses only
now are more of them deciding to pass
the cost back to the consumer Primark
have just said right from the beginning
we don't think we can make money out of
e-commerce we're not even going to going
to try we're going to focus all our
resources on the physical store and
protect our margins and that wasn't an
issue for the retailer until now Primark
is expected to close all 189 of its UK
stores tonight and it doesn't have an
online offering to fall back on
e-commerce was a Lifeline for a lot of
retailers during the pandemic they
couldn't open their stores but they were
still able to make some sales on the
internet but Primark didn't budge even
as consumers urged for it to offer
online shopping and even after its
Revenue dropped by almost 22 billion and
I think their confidence in this model
of having no digital sales and only
using stores I think was probably shaken
by the pandemic who knows what would
have happened if it had gone on for
longer I think the closures weren't
quite long enough to really tip the
scales and force them to fundamentally
rethink the model instead of traditional
online shopping in 2022 Primark launched
a trial service called click and collect
in select UK stores customers can select
certain products online then pick up
their orders in store so Primark still
has some cost to maintain its website
but it's cheaper than running a true
online shop so Primark makes a sale but
they don't have any of the logistical
costs that would be involved in packing
it up and then shipping it out to your
home and there's another bonus for
Primark since the customer has to go
inside to collect their purchase they're
likely to browse around and maybe even
buy more they make the sale online but
then they have a good chance of making
some extra sales when that person visits
them consumer psychologists call this
shopping momentum essentially once
you've already decided to make a
purchase it's easier to justify adding
more to your cart it always feels just
overwhelmingly busy with people who are
in there looking for bargains and it's
not just clothing Primark lures
consumers with beauty home and travel
products similar to a department store
what we like to say about primar here in
the US is that you know we're all
treasure without the hunt so customers
may go in for a new t-shirt and leave
with a suitcase but a Primark that I can
drive to and don't have to fly to is a
dream because that means there's no
limit to what I can buy and bring home
to carry this vast selection of items
Primark finds large retail spaces
because it relies on selling a lot it's
one of the largest retailers in the UK
by volume and one of the largest across
all of Europe last year Primark made
about 9.5 billion in sales revenue in
part by selling a lot of things at low
profit margins and it does this by
sourcing a lot of its clothing from Asia
combined with not offering online
shopping this enables primar to sell its
merchandise at lower prices even lower
than many other fast fashioned retailers
where they do have serious rivals on
Price is with the digital only players
like shien for example they are often
even cheaper than Primark but according
to the National Retail Federation 80% of
shopping still happens in store giving
Primark an edge over its digital only
competitors even so its instore shopping
model got off to a rocky start in the US
Primark opened its first Us store in
Boston back in 2015 although it was
already popular in the UK its us
expansion started slowly over 4 years it
opened nine stores after years of
experimentation primar learned it would
have to change to succeed in the us when
we first opened we took a similar store
size that we would have had in Europe
but when Primark opened its stores
across the Northeast it struggled to
find the right store density what they
found in the US is that retail is so
much more competitive there's a lot more
retail in
downtown areas in the US and than there
is in the UK for example so you just
can't support a massive store it's just
not possible to get enough revenue for
the size to support its large stor sizes
it needed a lot of foot traffic but
unlike the UK stores which were located
in constantly busy areas Us stores were
mostly in malls where during the week
foot traffic dwindled we learned that
actually 35,000 ft of retail selling
space is is actually the The Sweet Spot
for us they didn't face the commercial
pressure that a a publicly owned company
might have faced to suddenly open a 100
stores and and get really big ready
quickly and then possibly risk disaster
because they hadn't thought it through
the culture of primarch has always been
to take our time and and to test and
learn and we've done that in every
country where we've introduced the brand
this wasn't about you know growing
market share at all costs and the
overall retail Market is Shifting online
shopping hit a peak during Co but now
growth is beginning to slow as people
return to stores and I think that's
never been so important as it is since
we came out of Co I think there has been
a massive rediscovery of being in malls
being together physical shopping and I
think as a business that took the
decision a long time ago to to have that
as our core strategy um you know has
continued to allow us to be
successful it's that time of year when
vacant storefronts temporarily transform
into Spirit Halloween that spooky
seasonal retailer that's seemingly
everywhere overnight for Spirit
Halloween a pop-up lease is ideal
because then they're only paying for
space when they truly need it guess
what's finally open the spirit store
happy day happy day and with consumers
expected to spend a record amount for
the holiday spirit Halloween has opened
more stores than ever this year so how
does Spirit Halloween capitalize on
abandoned spaces in local markets and
how does it manage to transform those
vacant storefronts so quickly this is
the economics of Spirit Halloween the
first Spirit Halloween popped up in 1983
in Castro Valley California it was an
extension of founder Joe marver women's
clothing store traditionally October is
a very slow month for for retail General
and there was a Halloween store in the
Strip Center that he operated and he saw
that there were lines coming out store I
said that might be a good idea and so
with that he turned his Boutique into a
Halloween store and uh kind of the rest
is history in 1999 marver sold the
company to Spencer Gifts that mall store
known for gag gifts and it's built a
reputation among those who love
Halloween so much so that more than
2,000 fans showed up to the July grand
opening of the flagship store in New
Jersey but the retailer is hoping last
minute Shoppers come through the door
too one of the advantages is that
they're everywhere so if someone has
forgotten about Halloween and needs to
get a last minute costume and can't wait
for it to be delivered after it was
bought online then they can just pop
into a Spirit Halloween while Shoppers
can buy Halloween fair on the company's
website at any time none of its physical
locations operate year round Spirit
Halloween prefers a temporary lease
because it is not a year round business
so for them they want to save as much
money as possible on real estate and so
it makes much more sense for them to
take space temporarily spirit Halloween
says convincing landlords wasn't easy at
first years ago when we sat down with
landlords and said hey we've got this
idea we got a popup Halloween store or
we're going to come for two months we
get the look of uh you know really what
you know why why would I bother with
that though landlords tend to prefer
long-term leases popups can be an
alternative to empty space in the Years
following the Great Recession as retail
vacancies increased landlords found that
pop-ups were effective way of filling
space that had been vacant for a long
time because of course some revenue is
better than no revenue and to make
temporary leases more attractive to
landlords the company adds kickout
Clauses if they find a space where they
want to open but the landlord finds
another tenant who's willing to sign a
long-term lease before a certain day
maybe it's middle of June for example
then Spirit Halloween loses that
space for Spirit Halloween finding real
estate is a year-round business business
when stores shut down for one season the
company is already talking to landlords
about the next big spaces are key up to
50,000 Square ft often where big box
retailers used to live those storefronts
are often in shopping centers or strip
malls but can also be Standalone and
signing the lease is just the beginning
the retailer says setting up the stores
is another logistical challenge I mean
literally we are starting from scratch
in every single store we inherit an
empty
location and we have to bring in not
only all the merchandise but all the
fixturing we have to hire the entire
staff according to the National Retail
Federation spending on Halloween is
expected to hit a record $10.6 billion
in 2022 on average customers are
planning to spend $100 each on costumes
Decor candy and cards this year and 36%
of customers plan to shop at specialty
stores like Spirit Halloween and with
1,450 stores across across the US and
Canada it's one of the most ubiquitous
it's a sign of fall it's kind of like
you get your pumpkin spice latte you're
back to school you see Spirit Halloween
open up in shopping centers on your
drive to work one of its biggest
competitors Party City's popup Ranch
Halloween City operated 275 stores in
2019 and scaled back during the pandemic
Spirit Halloween's popup model has
become such a fixture of the Season that
it's inspired a new movie popup
Halloween store in creepy lot aome and
countless internet memes people joke
about how quickly the company moves in
after something else shuts down we kind
of enjoy the meme value of of spirit we
bring life and we bring joy we bring
energy we bring a whole you know new
reason and so uh the mean value of
spirit is recognition of of of that
value that's part of the reason Spirit
Halloween decided to open all of its
planned 14400 stores in 2020 while comp
competitors opened fewer during the
covid-19 pandemic in 2021 the company
said it experienced product delays and
increased shipping costs last year we
didn't realize the the magnitude of the
issue with the Spy chain until April and
when suddenly everything dried up by the
end of the season we had received all of
our merchandise but it was through it
was through some really difficult
cartwheels and somersaults the retailer
says all of its locations are fully
stocked this year I just mov with
Halloween
for fans of Halloween the company wants
to be the beginning of the holiday
coming to a Spirit Halloween is an event
it's something that the fans really look
forward to it's almost like the new
season and when we come that's when
Halloween starts and for landlords with
empty storefronts Spirit Halloween
continues to temporarily bring life back
to those abandoned
spaces Chipotle's menu only has a few
items but it's highly customizable born
in 1993 that's what's made Chipotle one
of the most successful fast casual
restaurant chains in the US but in
recent years Chipotle's faced many
challenges between 2015 to 2018 Chipotle
dealt with five foodborn illness
outbreaks like most of the restaurant
industry Chipotle's Revenue took a big
hit during the beginning of the coron
virus pandemic and today it's dealing
with inflation that's increased labor
transportation and food costs yet
despite these setbacks Chipotle sales
are actually growing here's how
Chipotle's focus on efficiency and
Innovation helped it bounce back and
become one of the country's most
valuable Quick Service chains this is
the economics of
Chipotle Chipotle's Revenue has
increased by more than 200% over the
past decade its stock price has
increased about 400% in The Last 5 Years
much of Chipotle's success comes from
its efficient and what it calls
transparent instore experience Chipotle
has really in a lot of ways made the
whole fast casual category for
restaurants it's not fast food it's not
full service they've generated a lot of
sales from people who want this
alternative that's seems fresher and
faster than fast food but it's not a
full service experience fast casual
design can help them reduce some of
their labor expenses which helps with
profits Chipotle's menu is relatively
small but it's easy to customize there's
tons of stuff you can put on your meal
that's proteins that's cheeses that's
vegetables that's all the salsas and
sauces and for customer that makes it
exciting you know they get lots of
different things they can customize
their meal with the more limited menu in
general is better for restaurants and
their profits it's less things to train
the restaurant workers on it's less
waste Chipotle's founder Steve ell
emphasized having an open kitchen he
wanted customers to be able to see the
ingredients and preparation in front of
them today employees work at individual
stations to serve already prepared
ingredients making the ordering process
more efficient for customers we can
serve as many as 100 customers within a
15-minute period what's a better way
than telling people that it's fresh
showing them let them come in and
discover for themselves this
transparency has been very important for
Chipotle especially after its food
safety issues after several outbreaks of
eoli salmonella and norovirus in
Chipotle restaurants the company
implemented several changes like
improving food preparation and storage
procedures encouraging sick employees to
stay at home and bringing on a new CEO
Brian nickel he really did emphasize
that they cleaned up their procedures
didn't happen immediately but with time
people start to forget things too there
hasn't been the big high-profile scares
that there were previously after several
outbreaks between 2015 and 2018
Chipotle's stock price took a hit
however its focus on its digital
ordering platforms helped Drive drive up
revenue and stock prices started to
climb back in 2008 Chipotle became one
of the first fast casual chains to
create an online store pickup model in
its first year Chipotle's digital sales
accounted for $13 million or just 1% of
its total sales in 2022 digital sales
grew to $3.4 billion that's now nearly
40% of Chipotle's food and beverage
Revenue if you're ordering online
digitally that is made for you at a
whole separate part of the kitchen which
is just dedicated to online orders
Chipotle's app and online ordering
systems were also vital during the
pandemic the pandemic obviously was
terrible for all restaurants but
Chipotle did have some advantages there
in that they had this whole digital
ordering platform really set up and
scaled beforehand when the pandemic
first hit we saw that people stopped
going to restaurants for some period of
time so we saw our sales drop uh pretty
significantly but it only took like a
week or two before we started to see
that while they first stopped visiting
restaurants the adoption of the digital
ordering really picked up very very
quickly and so I would say within the
first four weeks we had our digital uh
uh ordering soore from about 18% to it
at one point hit 70% Chipotle also
designed its stores to have two separate
prep stations called make lines one make
line is just for inore orders and the
other is for digital and Catering orders
this made food pickups quicker for
customers who didn't want to spend time
indoors this idea that we had the
digital make line so that as people were
ordering we could make food on the
digital make line and also serve
customers that were choosing to come in
so it was a seamless experience like
most stocks during 2020 they were still
lower than they were before the pandemic
but by the end of the first year into
the second year most stocks had you know
fully recovered we had our all-time high
in 2021 recently Chipotle has continued
to expand its digital ordering services
with a new pickup option for customers
called chipot Lanes let's go ahead and
take offer all the convenience of the
drivethru but when you order ahead of
time you know exactly what time to come
and so there's no ly you drive up and
you pull to our window you get your food
and off you go the first chipot Lane
opened in 2018 and there are already
nearly 600 across the US Chipotle says
at least 80% of new restaurant locations
opening in 20123 will have chipot Lanes
but that's just one example of how
Chipotle has continued to innovate to
attract customers social media has been
great for us because in addition to
making sure we're serving you know the
meals that that customers come to expect
at Chipotle we also want to be part of
culture Chipotle frequently uses social
media to attract younger consumers by
releasing recipe videos animated short
films Roblox games and social media
campaigns like the lid flip challenge
with major influencers Chipotle has also
used social media to drum up excitement
about new menu items and innovate its
menu options to keep up with consumer
Trends adding new things for customers
is very important to Chipotle and they
have a whole process for this where they
try and try these items in house really
test and learn before they test in
stores they like menu news whether it's
you know a steak item or a chicken item
alpastor quesadillas they want to keep
customers interested even if most of
their menu is staying the same so what's
next for Chipotle in general the online
ordering even when you pick it up in the
restaurant is just much more efficient
the company says it wants to open more
locations that are only used for online
pickup orders they won't have any
seating for customers this will also cut
down on labor costs since workers won't
need to clean seating areas and
bathrooms as often we think the idea is
let the customers choose which channel
they want now our job is to make sure
every channel is convenient it's easy
it's fast so that we don't give any
friction whatsoever but make sure every
experience that you can provide on every
channel is a great one a puma cotton
blend t-shirt on Vince's site cost $85
but the same shirt sells for $29.99 at
TJ Maxx so why does it cost less over 10
years the off-price retailer has opened
263 more stores in 2022 TJX which owns
TJ Maxx Marshalls and Homegoods brought
in almost $50 billion in sales revenue
more than Nordstrom's and Macy's
combined and the secret to its success
the company isn't shifting most of its
business online or using big data to
figure out what Shoppers want instead
it's sticking to a decades old Playbook
get the max for
minimim
[Music]
it's this is the economics of TJ Maxx
there are really two components to TJ
Maxx's strategy the bargain and the hunt
One Way TJ Maxx gets discounted Goods is
by buying excess merchandise and cancel
orders from other brands and retailers
essentially it takes advantage of
surplus and waste in the retail system
this allows the company to sell its
merchandise generally around 20 to 60%
below regular retail prices but there's
a catch just the fact that the price is
low is not enough what you need is also
a reference price because people don't
know how much things cost that's where
Alex says something known as the
anchoring effect comes in at TJ Maxx
most items have two prices the T J Maxx
price and a comparison price people
anchor the the regular price and then
they see exactly how much of a deal
they're getting and this way they really
understand what the value is that DJ
Maxx provides to them take these Rag and
Bone shorts a TJ Maxx in Manhattan sold
them for about $40 with a comparison
price of $50 that's a 20% discount but
the original price tag happened to be on
these shorts and it lists the price as
$195 that would be around 80% discount
and that comparison price is really just
an estimate on TJ Maxx's website there's
a message next to the comparison price
that says these prices are references to
regular retail prices where identical
items are not available we compare to
products of a similar type quality and
style these price tags aren't the only
way TJ Max helps customers feel like
they're getting a bargain the whole
positioning of of TJ Maxx is U if we
give you brand names for Less
and the reason why it's important is
because very often when you see low
price uh you think it's low price
because the quality of the product is
low but if the customer knows and trusts
the brand then they won't assume the
price is low because it's a bad product
instead Alex says they'll attribute it
to TJ Maxx's ability to get discounted
goods and because people often expect
name brand items to be more expensive
the brand itself acts as an anchor
emphasizing the fact that as a customer
you're getting a
deal uh makes people feel good it's not
only I'm getting a low price but I'm
actually getting a deal uh which makes
people feel good about themselves that
they're smart Shoppers TJ Maxx says it
gets its goods from about 21,000 vendors
and the inventory in its stores is
constantly turning so as a result people
tend to go more often to this type of
stores and also spend a little bit more
time in the store in search of something
across its companies TJX employs more
than 1200 buyers that each control
millions of dollars and has authority to
cut deals on the spot as a buyer for TJ
Maxx I'm always on the hunt let's say
you have a bathing suit brand and it's
the right before Memorial Day weekend
and they're stuck with extra bathing
suits that's when TJ Maxx buyers show up
at the showroom you know they can cut a
deal right on the spot and they can get
it to their stores within a week
department stores on the other hand can
take weeks to review and approve orders
from their buyers so TJ MOX buys the
merchandise quickly and gets it into the
store just as fast they have a saying
internally door to floor in 24 meaning
that any merchandise that shows up at a
store in the morning has to be on the
sales floor by the end of that day to
ensure speed merchandise often arrives
at stores already on racks that
employees wheel off trucks and move
straight onto the sales floor and once
it's there all the merchandise is laid
out differently than other retailers too
helping to create that treasure hunt
experience while most department stores
group items by brand TJ Maxx organizes
its inventory by type this means that
different brands can end up next to each
other on the same racks and since TJ
Maxx doesn't have walls dividing
sections of the stores or Brands it can
easily reconfigure the layout based on
changing inventory seeing all the
products and changing layout can
encourage impulse buying Shoppers know
that if they see something they like
they need to buy it now if they wait it
may be sold out or hard to find when
they come back once you take it home
things are changing dramatically because
now you're not buying something you you
are giving up something lots of research
has shown that giving up something is
more difficult than acquiring you're
willing to uh pay more uh not to give up
something than to buy something
retailers struggled through the rise of
e-commerce in the pandemic and while TJ
X's off-price retailers still took a hit
they have bounced back in 2021 TJX had
the highest sales in the company's
history a record it then beat the
following year and it's not because TJ
Maxx and the other off-price retailers
adapted but rather because they never
drifted away from their core strategy TJ
Maxx tends to perform pretty well in an
economic downturn because that's when
customers tend to be bargain conscious
and you know they offer really good
value for the money let's say you wanted
to buy a popular Rolex Daytona watch a
new one would cost you
$14,800 but if you wanted to buy a used
version of the same watch you might need
to pay over
$38,000 so why people spending more
money to get a used Rolex if you use
your watch primarily for 10 in the time
then we're not of the same mindset
here's why the used watch Market is
booming and what Rolex is doing to get
in on the action this is the economics
of used
[Music]
Rolexes experts suggest that it takes
about a year to make a Rolex and weight
list for new watches can last months to
years and because of that these days you
can't walk into any Rolex store any
Rolex dealer and just get any watch that
you want for the past few years as
demand has increased Rolex has not been
able to keep up with that demand their
production just can't match the number
of people that want a Rolex if you've
got 10 $220,000 to burn you really want
a watch you're probably going to go to
the resale Market because the watch that
you want is going to be available there
and so the prices on the resale Market
have then gone up because there's more
people going to that market 29% of
collectors reported paying more than
retail price for their most recent
pre-owned watch according to a report
from Boston Consulting Group and 40%
said that one of their top reasons was
that they were able to avoid long
waiting lists in the firsthand Market
this has created a boom in the secondary
Market pre-owned watch sales reached 22
billion in 2021 the used sector is
actually growing faster than the primary
market and for some people used watches
are worth more than new ones that's
because some rare styles are more
desirable or because Rolex has
discontinued certain models and colors
in in older model Rolex can have a
patina it can have some wear marks and
so those kind of personal details those
kind of personal age marks those are
things that collectors might want there
is also a bragging rights thing where if
you have a Rolex from the 70s or the 80s
you're able to say it's from this era
it's you know 20 30 years older than I
am and that is just kind of cool to
collectors in a way the market about a
decade ago was softer than it is right
now back then you could sell a watch and
get a return on it but you could also
sell a Rolex and it could have
depreciated value when you could lose
money on it these days you now will
likely make more money off of it if you
sell it on the resale Market much of the
success of the used watch Market is due
to the rise of online watch resale
marketplaces over the past decade that's
where people like Paul and Carol come in
can yell at get over there buddy the
husband and wife Duo run Bob's watches
an online Marketplace for buying selling
and trading luxury watches they say that
they currently have one of the largest
selections of used Rolex watches in the
world I started out in the watch
business because I could see that there
was no real safe transparent honest
place for people to buy and sell
pre-owned watches it's been an upward
Trend since 2010 we've been growing
consistently about 30 to 40%
year-over-year two years ago we did uh
$100 million in sales there's so much
more for us to tap into that we haven't
had the bandwidth to get to because the
growth has been so so fast and furious
and Paul and Carol love Rolexes sales of
used watches online already exceed
auction and store sales and one report
predicts they're going to reach close to
60% of the secondhand luxury Market by
2026 during the pandemic the stock
market goes crazy you have the kind of
crypto phenomenon you have meme stocks
happening and people have a lot of extra
capital and they're taking that in many
cases and they're putting it toward
assets um luxury goods and in a lot of
cases watches starting in 2020 used
luxury watches sold for 1.5 to three
times their retail prices Rolex is a
brand that's really recognizable in its
design it's you know easy to spot on the
street and a lot of people they'll see
that their friend has a given Rolex and
they think I want that too but Rolex the
company only sold new watches which
meant that the brand wasn't involved
with used watch sales that is until late
2022 Rolex opened a certified pre-owned
program for its used watches retailers
can send used Rolexes that are at least
3 years old back to the watch maker the
certified pre-own program verifies that
a watch is an authentic Rolex and works
properly then retailers can sell the
watch with an official Rolex certificate
the program is already active in one
retail chain in six different countries
another chain of official Rolex
retailers in the US will enter the
program this may buying a watch with
Rolex certification could be a draw for
firsttime buyers you're buying a watch
on the internet it can be a little bit
of a daunting experience of all the
watches on our website today almost 50%
of them already have the original box
and papers from Rolex we've offered a
CPO program a certified pre-owned
program now for almost 5 years the only
thing really new about it is that Rolex
is certifying and doing the paperwork
behind it so I don't feel that there's
any increased competition but I do feel
that the market is big enough for
everybody to participate today people
buy Rolexes online the way that they
might buy toilet paper so it's really
not a premium or specialized experience
there's still that consumer that wants
to have that experience of going into a
store of being waited on of kind of
being shown watches from a glass display
case and making it feel more special
because they're buying something of such
a high value this certified pre-owned
program means that Rolex can take a cut
out of a market that it previously left
untapped but things might continue to
shift for the luxury watch Market the
used watch Market is cooling down as
sellers eager to make a profit have
flooded the market with inventory recent
data shows the number of Rolex watches
available to buy second in hand roughly
doubled from the beginning of 2022 to
September of the same year on those
really coveted kind of brand name
watches so to speak the ones that
collectors talk about the resale value
has gone down a little bit resellers
people that watch that market they do
say that the prices have come back down
to earth a little bit but the volume of
sales the amount of sales happening that
Still Remains pretty high we're seeing
still a large number of transactions in
the resale Market your day and day out
Rolex is still retaining a lot of value
on the resale Market you can still get a
pretty good return turn for it as with
any resale Market there is a risk that
the Rolex Market can fall out at any
time 5 years ago we might not have been
talking about how crazy this Market is
and 5 years from now we might not be
the market is so large that to a certain
extent both things can be true you know
people that watch this Market will say
that that's just actually a reflection
of how big the market is now where it
can behave in many different ways just
because it is this kind of really large
transactional Marketplace this is what
Nintendo originally was yes it was a
playing card company and this is
Nintendo today me Mario consoles theme
parks even movies so what has driven the
$44 billion Empire this is the economics
of
Nintendo Nintendo is different from its
competitors Sony and Microsoft thanks in
part to its lowcost Hardware Microsoft's
Xbox makes no profit on its Hardware
consoles are actually sold at a loss in
the market so when somebody goes and
they buy an Xbox at their local retailer
uh we're subsidizing that purchase
somewhere between $1 and $200 with the
expectation that we will recoup that
investment over time through accessory
sales and storefront and Sony only
recently began to make a profit on the
PlayStation 5 then there's Nintendo
their technology is usually five or six
years behind in terms of
state-of-the-art but that means that
they're cheaper to produce and that
means Nintendo is much much more
profitable on their Hardware business
about half of Nintendo's profit in 2022
came from Hardware Sales they've
dominated the market when it comes to
handheld consoles one of its big
successes the Game Boy launched in
1989 Nintendo was really early to the
party uh with handheld they're kind of
credited with inventing the console
although they were probably third or
fourth the game boy had a longer battery
life compared to some of its competitors
for four Shades of Gray nuanced gameplay
and had Tetris one of the top selling
video games of all time eventually
Nintendo's Game Boy became the third
most sold console in the company's
history selling 119 million units to
date the company continued to innovate
releasing new hardware for its games
from the GameCube Nintendo DS the wiii
and to its most recent success the
switch with more than 122 million units
sold you can play it at home like a
console on your big screen TV but you
could pick it up and take it on the go
and it becomes a handheld device and
that's pretty novel we haven't really
seen anything that's a hybrid like that
before sales of the switch device and
its games accounted for about 94% of
Nintendo sales revenue in its 2021
fiscal year and today it's the second
bestselling game console in Nintendo's
history and continues to be a driving
factor of its Revenue the success of
Nintendo's consoles is also due to its
software in other words its games in
2022 Nintendo had had 19 first party
titles that sold over a million units
each exclusive to its consoles the
difference between the others and
Nintendo is that Nintendo historically
has produced about 50% of all the games
sold on its Hardware system and the
other guys are typically under 10% of
the game sold on their systems so they
make a small fraction of the software
that's played on PlayStation and Xbox
Nintendo makes more than half recent
Point Animal Crossing New Horizon's
release in April 2020 created higher
demand for the only console carrying it
the switch Nintendo makes games
exclusively for the most part for its
own devices if you want to play a
Nintendo game like Legend of Zelda you
need Nintendo Hardware in fact
Nintendo's first party games generate
over 70% of its sales its best sellers
in 2022 were all Nintendo first party
games and the type of content Nintendo
makes is also different than its
competitors let's keep in mind
Nintendo's characters are very
cute
Mario Nintendo is known for making
familyfriendly games for the most part
so it appeals to a different crowd than
some of the other Publishers you won't
see blood or Gore or foul language but
even Nintendo couple years ago dabbled
into the shooter genre when we think of
Shooters right we think of Call of Duty
fortnite uh they take a very
familyfriendly approach with Splatoon
it's a shooter but you're shooting
paintballs the company's next iteration
bringing these familyfriendly characters
to a larger Arena and building another
generation of fans in February 2023
Nintendo opened its first theme park
outside of Japan and in April it's
releasing a Super Mario Brothers movie
starring Chris Pratt it's a me a Mario
that's smart because that's going to
expose the Nintendo brand to hundreds of
millions of people who haven't ever
owned a switch I don't think that
Nintendo is necessarily worried about
whether somebody who goes to the theme
park will buy buy a Nintendo console or
buy a game but they want those people to
be aware of the Nintendo Brands and they
want them to know who Mario is and who
Zelda is and who Yoshi is and who Pikman
is it is risky to start a new franchise
and sometimes new properties just don't
resonate um but they have plenty a very
deep library and they've stuck with that
for the most part and iterated on it and
modernized it we'll probably be playing
Legends of Zelda for another 20 30 years
Mario is probably not going anywhere you
now he's just going to live forever and
keep that mustache and keep everyone
happy for many years to come this Barnes
& Noble in Pikesville Maryland used to
be in a 24,000 ft space in this building
now it's moved across the street to a
space that's less than half the
size and with the downsizing came a new
look and new books chosen specifically
for this store's customers it's all part
of Barnes & Noble strategy to tailor
each of the company's more than 600
location to local tastes Barnes & Noble
is adopting the strategy of independent
bookstores that it once put out of
business here's how the book seller is
implementing its new approach and why it
thinks this new strategy will sell more
books this is the economics of Barnes
and
[Music]
Noble Barnes & Noble was first founded
in 1873 in 1971 Leonard Rio acquired the
company which set off a period of growth
the retailer went public in 1993 in an
era when it was opening Superstores
across the country in the 1990s and
2000s Barnes & Noble bookstores really
looked like large supermarkets filled
with books usually anchoring strip
centers in the suburbs or rural areas
and whether in Phoenix or Maryland or
Ohio the stores had the same books with
the same furniture and the same layout
it either had one floor or it had two if
had two it had enormous escalators going
out with this huge sort of open space in
the middle to an upper floor that model
happened to be extremely scalable they
were trying to fill their stores with
books and infrastructure at the lowest
cost possible so they wanted to order
all the same types of bookshelves the
same type of furnishings and decorations
and other autra mths so the company grew
and fast those huge stores carried more
books at lower prices than independent
book stores we all remember the romcom
new got mail Joe Fox I'm in the book
business I am in the book business so
many closed when Barnes & Noble came to
town they weren't able to compete with
the title selection or prices that
Barnes Noble offered but big stores and
large inventories weren't enough to save
Barnes & Noble from a digital threat
Amazon was able to offer kind of like
Barnes & Noble had in the past a huge
selection of titles at lower prices than
Barnes & Noble could because it didn't
have the cost of real estate and other
uh costs that Barnes & Noble was
shouldering and it sunk a lot of money
trying to keep Pace particularly in Nook
it's e-reader business take your story
wherever you want it to go but nothing
helped stop the bleeding the company's
Revenue has declined since
2012 then in 2019 hedge fund Elliot
Management Corporation acquired the
chain and installed James da who led
British retailer waterstones and founded
his own independent bookstore da books
as CEO it felt entirely intuitive to me
that you allow each bookstore to run as
an independent bookstore they will
create much more interesting much more
Dynamic much more engaging bookstores
and that meant reminding people about
the appeal of inperson versus online
shopping what you're missing is the
opportunity to kind of read the book
flaps of all the other books that are
there and maybe get recommendations from
the local book seller who's working
there the company says it wanted to
emphasize the experience of visiting a
physical bookstore so its new strategy
strips stores of the cookie cutter look
and feel that had helped the change grow
its revenue and store count some
locations have moved on from The Big Box
model to smaller stores and in these
smaller spaces they are reconfiguring
the stores so that they're more of a
maze and less of a supermarket aisle
plus the company says each individual
store has more autonomy over what books
to order and how to display them here at
the Pikesville Maryland location the
store manager says that customers like
romance books from Black authors and
lots of fiction so the large romance
section is at the front of the store and
there's a huge display right in the
center celebrating Black History Month
store managers can also choose how to
run promotions like this buy one get one
50% off deal on specific fiction books
chosen by the team here Brooklyn has a
very different demographic very
different set of customers a very
different set of book interests to let's
say somebody in Alabama in Georgia who
is the best person to judge what those
particular communities want to by it the
book sellers in those communities the
company has also been listening to its
store managers on wider Trends manga was
a small part of our assortment we had
maybe five six Bays of books on manga
And yet when these book sellers were
reorganizing their stores they were
coming back to us saying we want to do
38 you know we want to do 42 which was
just almost sort of incomprehensible
except that's what they said their
customers would respond to D also used
this localizing strategy to turn around
British books store chain water stones
which reported a 42.9 million pound loss
across 268 stores in 2012 compared to a
16.32 million pound profit across 278
stores 6 years later the two businesses
are on paper identical it had had
identical histories um and had reached
an identical point of failure that's why
Barnes & Noble relinquished some control
to individual stores but that comes with
its own set of of challenges for the
company you could walk into a bookstore
and find out that it's really not doing
well the manager's choices aren't
appealing to customers and books aren't
selling still Barnes & Noble says the
strategy is promising for the first time
in more than a decade the company is
planning on opening more stores than it
closes in
2023 we've seen a balancing in which
much higher percentage of our sales are
coming from books and books are growing
really very dramatically if you run
better bookstores you sell more books
this is what Lego products looked like
in the
1980s and this is a Lego Product
now that's because the company has
become more than just blocks they have
video games movies theme parks all these
activities which ultimately reinforce
the core which is the sale of Lego sets
all that content helped it become the
world's largest toy maker breaking in
billions of dollars every year here's
how the company uses licensing deals in
media to expand it its customer base and
build its content Empire this is the
economics of Lego Lego is 90 years old
it was founded in Denmark in 1932 and
initially it was a company that made
wooden toys but then in the 1950s it
launched its trademark product the one
we all know now the the plastic Lego
brick since then Lego has beat out
Hasbro and metel to become the biggest
toy brand worldwide in the first 6
months of 2022 the company's Revenue h
27 billion Danish croner or about $ 3.47
billion up 177% from 2021 and it's
anticipating growing demand so much so
that the company is building two new
factories in the US and Vietnam Lego has
made the bricks the building blocks of
its business Lego is still essentially a
toy company what what they always say is
their core is still to make the plastic
bricks for kids but of course they do
now do a lot more than that some of
LEGO's first moves into content started
in the 199 90s Island behind us when the
company's sales slumped it was trying
everything from new toys to electronics
to theme parks can you find the power
Bionicle Bionicle came along in the
early 2000s and that was a time when the
LEGO brand was actually in danger of
becoming a little bit stale the bionical
franchise featured buildable action
figures and multiplatform storytelling
agile determined Unstoppable the
franchise built a Content Universe
through Comics books movies and video
games the BET proved successful in 2003
when the toy maker saw a 26% loss in net
sales Bionicle was its bestselling line
and it really revitalized the brand and
and showed them a way that they could
engage audiences with different types of
content with cartoons
movies comics and it wasn't just
Original Stories Lego released its first
sets based off of licensed material in
1999 Star Wars in 2005 it it brought
that into content with a 5-minute short
called revenge of the brick that aired
on Cartoon
Network it was a Twist of course on the
Revenge of the Sith which was the the
Star Wars movie which came out at the
time that really paved the way for the
for the content Partnerships which we've
seen in subsequent years that Lego twist
has since been put to use on all sorts
of franchises like Batman Marvel and
Jurassic world really we're now used to
seeing not just the basic Lego kits but
Lego Star Wars kits and and so on that's
really an integral part of what Lego
does now so it's really the content has
has changed Lego's identity we think of
it as part of these popular franchises
which we all know like Marvel and
licensed material was on full display on
the company's Smash Hit 2014's The Lego
Movie which grossed over $450 million
worldwide it held the top spot in the US
box office for 3 weeks after its release
Superman Wonder Woman the mermaid
Michelangelo and the 2002 NBA allar the
goal of the Lego movie was to Market
Lego to a wider audience I think it was
a lot more successful than anyone
imagined it was a very successful movie
in its own right a big hit at the box
office that laid the template for for a
lot of the content creation that Lego
has done since then Lego and Warner
Brothers released three more feature
films the latest in 2019 none earned as
much as the first of course there is a
risk of oversaturation Lego doesn't want
to do too much but but I think think
they're still very much at the stage of
growing in a lot of markets content has
helped the toy maker break into new
places like China where Lego is growing
its presence of the 66 new stores it
opened in the first half of 2022 46 of
those were in China almost 42% of the
company's 833 locations are there movies
and games assist in raising awareness of
the brand the main challenge Lego faced
in in New Markets like China is that the
grown-ups the parents just don't really
know about Lego they don't have Lego in
their in their own backgrounds like a
lot of grown-ups in in the US and Europe
do and using licensed material in that
content also helps reach more audiences
being part of these popular franchises
like The Avengers for example is a great
way for Lego to to reach out to all
kinds of different Generations people
across the world people who don't
necessarily even know Lego content is
also a way for it to appeal to its adult
fans as the brand has been trying to do
in recent years find your flow
build with Lego bricks reality TV show
Lego Masters for example features adults
building extreme Creations out of the
titular plastic bricks the original Lego
fans took to Lego as kids and they're
now grown up and and a lot of those
people are still very keen on Lego and I
think Lego very smartly realized that a
lot of those people would be willing to
to buy kits that are are pretty complex
pretty expensive and are designed
specifically for for grown-ups the
company has its eyes set Beyond just the
$2 dimensional screen last April Lego
and epic games announced a partnership
to build a digital experience in the
metaverse all of this content certainly
in the company's current thinking the
movies the games that all is there to
support the core product which is the
same as it has been for decades the
plastic brick your last pizza probably
came in a box like this it's cardboard
stur and most importantly keeps your
cheese from getting stuck to the lid and
that's thanks to Domino's whose founder
is widely credited with creating the
corrugated pizza box it's just one of
the company's Innovations not in pizza
but in
delivery in 2022 more than 40% of online
delivery orders for major pizza chains
were from dominoes here's how the
company made its name in the pizza
delivery market and why this
foundational piece of its business is
facing new challenges this is the
economics of
Domino's Domino's it's a
Del dominoes originally called Dominics
acquired its first restaurant in 1960 in
ipsilanti Michigan and jumped into the
delivery business the same year
something very few restaurants were
doing at the time you're now we think of
delivery as being so ubiquitous I mean
so many types of restaurants have
delivery But Domino's was there very
early at scale one reason it's become so
well known for its delivery is a
campaign the company started in the 80s
PR ing delivery in less than 30 minutes
within 30 minutes only Domino's Pizza
delivers in 30 minutes or less people
really did have the sense that once they
ordered that pizza they were going to
get it to their homes quickly and I
think that really helped for marketing
Domino's ended that guarantee in 1993
after a delivery driver struck another
vehicle resulting in a lawsuit but by
then the company had cemented its place
in delivery and in the half century
since Domino's was founded it's paid off
it took the biggest slice of pizza chain
sales in
2022 Domino's success is due in part to
creativity and every step of its
delivery process starting with stores
many are small and often with little or
no dining space a model the company has
said allowed for lower rents and reduced
store expenses over the years Domino's
has also focused on establishing more
than 6,500 locations in the US and has
worked with franchisees to extend their
reach
so one part of Domino's strategy is
what's called Fortress which is making
sure there's enough pizza shops in a
certain mile radius that wherever your
order goes one of those pizza shops can
handle it and it can help get it to your
house quickly the company's supply line
is also structured to make the pizza
creation process as quick and uniform as
possible Domino's has 25 supply chain
centers in the US where dough is mixed
and toppings are prepared before being
sold to to franchise stores where pizzas
are assembled and baked the more pizzas
that are sold the more money Domino's
makes from its supply chain it made up
59% of Domino's Revenue in
2021 the next part of the process is
ordering in 2008 the company rolled out
its Advanced online ordering system
which included a customized Pizza
Builder and the Pizza Tracker so the
Pizza Tracker is something that Domino's
invented they will let you know where it
is in the process it's whether it's
being cooked whether it's out for
delivery where they're approaching
Domino's has continued to introduce new
ordering options Pizza Emoji sent
Domino's ordered smiley face then
there's the last step of the process
getting the pizza from the kitchen to
your home from working with special
kinds of insulated bags to creating 3D
car top signs Domino's has been a big
innovator in this step the company has
experimented with several methods of
delivery vehicles helicopters electric
bikes self-driving cars even cars with a
heated Pizza Oven it's really putting
the whole brand behind delivery in a lot
of ways but after years at the top of
delivery Domino's is facing new
challenges companies like Uber Eats
GrubHub and door Dash are eating at
Domino's business in the US as drivers
leave pizza for apps with more flexible
hours it's contributed to an
industrywide delivery driver shortage
other chains like Papa John's and Pizza
Hut have both started working with some
of these apps but Domino's has resisted
they argue that that makes it more
profitable because you're not having to
pay an outside service to deliver that
pizza and to Market that pizza on their
app and it keeps them closer to their
customers as the company has faced these
issues its shares have slumped from a
high at the end of
2021 now Domino's is exploring new
options the company is building out a
fleet of electric delivery vehicles to
recruit new drivers ERS and it's now
offering customers what it calls a $3
tip to pick up their own pie we see you
carry out Heroes you know it's much
cheaper for them if their customers pick
up their own pizza and so they are
getting in the pickup game in a big way
as Domino's continues to Grapple with
these issues investors and customers
will be watching for future
[Music]
Innovations